le dodo line le train de bush passé oui
c'est ça cécile pas encore ouvert la
porte parole du mouvement
à voir aux gens que ça faisons comme les
chiens à l'arrière des voitures
[Musique]
j'ai une question c'est est un mec hyper
technologique
tu vas tout ça comment ça se fait que tu
prends des notes un bout de papier avec
un crayon je vais expliquer quand j'ai
fait l'école de journalisme on m'a dit
les fiches cuisine ou nature très
pratique parce que tu peut les lire en
gros dans n'importe quelles conditions
c'est à dire faible éclairage ou
éclairage très vifs tout à l'heure à la
conférence en sais pas si on sera dans
le noir écrit là-dessus je vais
vachement bien le voir et parfois c'est
en tout petit et comme je suis vieux
dans chaque fois que j'écris j'ai
imprimé et ça j'en ai plus besoin il
faut je les écris on dirait quoi
eh bien je travaille enfin je fais sans
rentrer sur un site de rencontre les
ennemis ont simplement dit cette année
merci ça va super chaud que je de leur
monnaie qui chanta de boney m
clio j'écoute un peu de reggae je me
fais plaisir bravo moi qu'est ce que tu
fais là qu'on est bien et ce à des fins
du tourisme alors à ce qui paraît à
londres il brille en débit qui arrivait
ya pas longtemps qu'on va une le guide
touristique de nos grands noms on a une
conférence sur le royal belge du très
bon travail et on peut commencer
donc là on est parti à londres on a un
centre à ce qu on est parti pour aller
voir les derniers potins sur harry
potter des expositions y potter les
derniers smartphones devraient de plus
le 7 sept
on est tous vraiment intéressant à voir
donc là on est bien entouré guillaume
voilà toute la clique droit de supprimer
le monde regarde sa place quoi ces
bustes ses plus gros tubes et sucre on
s'est un peu schizophrénique victoire
quand même en essais de déception
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on m'a dit que mon petit morceau
pp mettra de la musique m'a valu ce
n'est pas un flim sur le cyclisme
[Musique]
ça suffit car des lacs maintenant ne
serait pas bien ça le problème de tout
ça c'est que les gens ont l'impression
que le travail face à mater les mamans
du coup d'oreille messieurs
c'est du 10 août au rayo bon on est en
place la rega le lancement des nouveaux
même plus on puisse y être en plus cette
pro qui va pas tarder à arriver le temps
de boire une petite canette c'est du
ginger rôle si vous connaissez j'ai
découvert cette fois que je prenais
l'avion à las vegas que l'étoile ginger
holt carrément pas toi c'est très
bizarre
wen a écouté ça pique un peu c'est
bizarre si vous connaissez un
commentaire mark et moi parce que moi je
suis pas un spécialiste du genre
mais ce serait pas monsieur qu'à taper
un 6/6 à monaco alors nico général
jamais ce que je vais en avoir dans les
mains j'ai parole de l'irs one + 7
promet je dis pas qu'ils l'apprennent
d'accord bon ok bien qu'appelée très bel
écran j'adore l'appareil photo
rétractable à qui rapporte gros sort
super joli c'est un magnifique écran
puis à un arrière violet qui est
magnifique
les bourgs achetez achetez le il est
beau il est beau et si ça vous plaît pas
vous le donner à près d'accord et c'est
ça on va y penser
[Musique]
donc là on est arrivé vous avez juste
derrière la scène on va y avoir la
présentation des nouveaux venus dans ces
quelques instants derrière toute la
régie technique
[Musique]
messi
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur vous travaillez là
c'est ça oui je alors qu'on a glissé one
piece est pourrait décevoir depuis cette
tour où elle est si quelqu'un apprécier
un jour le one piece système c'est
exactement le même s'il a proposé à peu
de choses près
par contre il ya quand même quelques
améliorations super pour le repas se
font circuler comme les haut parleurs
stéréo
tout ça ça s'est super bien d'autant que
j'étais celle que cette fois je peux
vous dire que les états sont mortels
c'est exactement la même ici est ce ça
ces bonnes nouvelles après après
franchement pour là aussi sensiblement
ce que ceux qui aiment pas les très bas
rhin curve et et cetera suffisait pas
salir est plein il restera donc ça ça va
il est quand même assez sympa m'a dit
que j'aimais pas motorisé par exemple il
reste surtout au même prix que le
système bravo monsieur ça c'est grave
absolument
en attendant de pouvoir le tester pour
l'instant on n'a pas
on n'a pas encore eu ce qu'on aura
normalement d'ici une ou deux semaines
ont peut-être que je veux tu toi tu
l'auras 80 logements ce geste j'espère
aura android la chaîne de musulmans
monsieur un test au début début juin
absolument dessus est-ce que là on est
pas mal comme ça couine fillon sur une
table à l'espace de démonstration
illustre bien l'amitié frandroid ce
diable
beauparlant côtoient l'ont bien on va
parler de ce smartphone j'ai déjà tourné
d'où une plus cette prod là je vous
parle du wan plus est il est juste là
alors la grosse différence que vous
allez avoir ce maillot là plus d'une
grosse différence en termes de
performance et la même chose
qualcomm snapdragon 855 vous avez soit 6
giga de ram sont 8 gigas de ram
ici pas de douzy viendront dans le foot
national ce en matière de stockage ou
256 go de stockage également bien
évidemment le design change pas
énormément par rapport au modèle de
l'année dernière fin d'année dernière
c'est à dire par rapport aux 6 t vous
avez toujours la petite encoche sur le
soulager les specs qui s'affiche
c'est quand même moi j'ai le modèle de
développement voulait pas j'ai tout
encoches là sur le dessus tibor labour
l'absolu le design ne changera pas
toujours le petit bouton ici pour venir
choisir le mode silencieux ou sonnerie
c'est ça c'est pas mal le bouton pour
l'allumer
le petit bouton de volume son côté
toujours de la recharge en guise
d'excusé bien évidemment de la recharge
rapide un smartphone comme surtout la
grande tétée nous proposer un double
module photo l'arrière avec notamment la
fameuse caméra de sony lit-et-mixe 586
avec une ouverture de f
1.7 le deuxième module photo c15
négative celle qui me servira pour votre
portrait pour il est évoqué ici il n'ya
pas du train d'entendre ici il n'ya pas
non plus de zoom optique x 2 x 3 combat
se contentent its et sony mx 5 186 mais
qui marche parfaitement bien à la base
est toujours un écran amoled qui marche
parfaitement bien sereine plus elle sait
je dirais un web plus 6 t qui a évolué
et qui a grandi qui est plus performant
il fera plus de choses qui aura une
meilleure autonomie avec le matri de
3700 millions terreur ici pas de 4
millions terreur mais vous avez de la
recharge rapide ça va assez bien
on en reparlera plus tard parce que pour
l'instant je n'ai pas testé donc sarko
autonomie je peux pas encore vous en
parler mais connaissant le cahier des
charges du wan plus que les centres de
travail qu'est départ en bus
je voulais absolument pas que ce
smartphone sans vraiment en fait on a
exactement le même format si vous
regardez que sur le droit de plus ce
système même format on a un écran de 6
41 pouces joli tout est neuf et la voix
qui fâchent manque houle sont bien sûr
les haut parleurs stéréo qui font leur
apparition dont beaucoup plus immersif
lorsque vous allez me regarde un film
lorsque vous allez jouer un jeu c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment cool
c'est vraiment une belle évolution si
vous avez loin de plus si ce n'est que
vous êtes vraiment gamer ça peut
vraiment avoir un sens après une pause
6-6 vraiment que tu es donc je pense pas
qu'il faille changer pour ce smartphone
là si par contre vous avez un modèle
antérieur
attendez de 2017 ou encore anciens ça
pourrait avoir un sens de passer au
dessus parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment une belle bête cela le même
capteur d'empreintes digitales que sur
le one piece est propre c'est à dire 5
et en 2005 il a permis qu'on peut
atteindre votre but dessus parce
ça y est vous êtes déverrouiller ça va
très vite c'est vraiment vraiment cool
ce que vous avez un capteur qui amélioré
qui est un peu plus grands qui fait 7 mm
au lieu de 6 mm et par contre si on a
vraiment en tout cas le même que celui
sur le one piece est pro il ya un vrai
cap par rapport aux une publicité ça
pour coup c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressants comme le plus cette pro et
on ne seront que six jeunes où elle joue
tout ça on en reparlera très très très
prochainement là aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment histoire faire un petit tour de
le regarder dans moi je trouve bien moi
je suis assez séduit alors on a deux
tarifs différents du config si giga de
ram 128 jir du stockage à 559 euros et 8
gigas de ram 256 go de stockage à 609 le
roux est extrêmement bien placé en tarif
là on est vraiment sur la définition du
flagship coeur si vous n'avez jamais eu
de russie cité et si vous faisait de
l'oeil
celui-là est vraiment intéressant et
surtout s'ils voulaient pas mettre un
peu plus d'argent qui l'entouré 500 600
euros et vous voulez pas forcément aller
sur un monde plus c'est trop le one
piece est vraiment faire votre affaire
bon
dans les coulisses les dans la zone
médias la zone de démonstration médias
vous avez tous les médias du monde
entier au club ce qu'est ce qu'ils sont
invités qui seront les gagnants peuvent
venir tester vous avez aussi bien le one
plus c'est trop que le one plus est que
les nouveaux écouteurs
les deux lettres j'aime manger le nom on
en reparle d'ici quelques jours qui sont
présentés dont vous avez tout de même
tout ce qui est là qu on peut venir
prendre en main tc découvrir voir un peu
ce que ça donne
et puis en plus pour une fois ce qui va
mal c'est que l'éclairage s écoule
pressé par le général c'est soulant sont
souvent la guérilla regardez vous à les
éclairages les bouquins poignet qui nous
permet de bosser correctement c'est
vachement plus surtout le statut
vachement sympa nous devons choisir
espèce de des normands gars allons vous
voyez le truc qui ouvre la bal adecco
est assez sympa et de vous emmener avec
moi faire un petit tour comme ça vous
vous découvrir il ya plein de monde a
ici c'est vraiment un endroit qui est
qui écoule jamais dans le tube du tunnel
world tourner du côté plat du côté de la
grande salle qui est un endroit que
juste signaler ici là c'est mon rôle
j'adore cet endroit ça va vraiment fait
un super boulot de scénographie
c'est vraiment cool et l'on a retiré du
côté de la salle principale où vous avez
eu la confirmation que instante qui
était vachement cool
d'ailleurs à bravo à qui sa présentation
juste gold sommes donc là il ya la salle
et puis derrière vous avez l'espace de
démonstration hors média donc savoir qui
est aussi tous les les fans de la
commune les comme l'a fait il ya tous
les fans guen plus jeune clay vrai
qu'ils sont là donc ça c'est vachement
cool
ceux ci une particularité de vote +1
vraiment de s'appuyer sur sa communauté
pour tout ce qui est développement de l'
os parler des fonctionnalités parler du
produit vrai vrai lien qui est hyper
forte la communauté sas et il est très
très très très très gros point fort du
panama est d'ailleurs on va en reparler
je vais aller rencontrer la communauté
je les présents ce samedi 18 samedi 18
mai de 11h à 18h fnac des ternes c'est
le pop up store 2
dewaele place je serais avec mon pote
jérôme de now tech avec quentin quentin
cougnaud donc on va être là on va faire
de l'oeil boxing on va vous rencontrez
donc des nous voir venez nous rencontrer
savaty par cette fois passé un très bon
moment ensemble
ça bosse à sa bosse dur j'ai
l'impression que tout à l'heure avec mon
truc tu te balades mais tu n'es pas
grand chose on comment ça je vais pas
monsieur g1 gh1 la pression monsieur
serge savard équipe est un bel objet
monsieur merci au monde le dit souvent
explique moi encore je tiendrai lourd
encore c'est cool bah écoutes je te
remercie moi j'aime beaucoup la tienne
aussi le son je vais rester là dessus
mais si c'est pareil que sur le one
piece est promouvoir dubois moi je
déteste mais écouter de la musique sur
téléphone avec les haut parleurs
du téléphone ouais là ça m'a quand même
bien bloquer le
c'était cool cool ma poule
[Musique]
on est en train de louper le métro l'un
monsieur le mans prend des risques il
est plus d'embargo tu peux sortir
exactement ça je peux le sortir de ma
poche je vais pouvoir maintenant changer
ma carte sim me remettre dedans
exactement on risque alors les problèmes
[Musique]
est-ce que tu serais en train de jubilé
au plus tard la ddhc loisel one for the
money enfin le chien non plus failli à
gênés nord groupe avait demandé à dire à
pépé mais bon
on est un peu coincé tout petit bain
c'est tout
[Musique]
on a un problème tps il ya pas de prise
électrique je préfère mon montage entre
les sièges attends je vais jouer mais
pas elles sont déprimées trick à elles
sont là les prises électriques nickel
ces bons jeux proposés allant verdict va
être très long mais ça va être bon voilà
bon je t'assure je suis prêt à m'assoir
le ending des collines vacances merci